bloomberg businessweek senior national
correspondent Joshua green at her table
this morning and author of this new book
devil's bargain
Steve Bannon Donald Trump and the
storming of the presidency
Joshua green when did Steve Bannon first
meet Donald Trump well a lot earlier
than most people realize and I tell the
story in the book of how Bannon and
Trump were actually introduced in 2010
by a veteran Republican activist named
David bossy who Trump had begun turning
to to tutor him and give him some
political advice on the idea that he was
going to run for president and one day
bossy who knew Bannen from their
conservative Washington circles said hey
I'm going up to advise Donald Trump at
Trump Tower why don't you come along and
Bannen thinking this would be a great
lark I decided to go along and by all
accounts Bannon and Trump hit it off
right off the bat and he has been a part
of Trump's orbit ever since what do they
have in common and what separates the
two men well they have quite a bit in
common despite appearances in very
different backgrounds they both went to
military high schools they both are
business guys deal makers Trump in
Manhattan real estate Bannon Wall Street
finance and later in Hollywood and they
were both deeply involved in and care
about the entertainment industry Trump
of course as the apprentice but Bannon
went moved from financing films he
produced Sean Penn films Anthony Hopkins
films decided to get over into the
creative side became a conservative
documentary filmmaker that eventually
led him into the Tea Party movement he
met Andrew Breitbart the conservative
publisher and took over Breitbart news
when Andrew Breitbart died in 2012 and
that really put him on the path to
Donald Trump and in becoming a real
player in Washington politics how are
they different not just in their
backgrounds but philosophically well
they're different in the sense that
Trump was born rich his father was a big
developer in New York City
whereas bannin is the blue-collar Irish
Catholic working-class son of a
telephone line
he grew up in Richmond Virginia so
financially they have very different
backgrounds I think in terms of politics
Bannon is someone who has always cared a
lot about culture about tradition he
long before he met Trump he had
developed his own idea of a nationalist
economic populism whereas Trump I don't
think had a particular political agenda
that he was trying to pass he used to be
a Democrat then he famously ran on the
Reform Party ticket later on he became a
Republican so I think that they have
different political backgrounds although
Trump seemed to recognize and Bannon
beginning in around 2013 or 2014 that
here was a guy in a politics that could
work for Trump they could get Trump
elected as a Republican president and as
we all know it did did Steve Bannon take
Donald Trump seriously upon meeting him
that first time in their subsequent
interactions after he did not I don't I
think he went up in the spirit of this
is gonna be fun I mean since Donald
Trump celebrity everybody knows Donald
Trump he was the apprentice at the time
so you know I don't think that Bannon
had any inkling that Trump was serious
about running for president but
embossing and Ben and I tell the story
in devil's devil's bargain went out and
pulled together what is called Oppo
research opposition research so that
they could go up and essentially give
Trump a sense of what he was likely to
encounter from his political opponents
if he would get into the race and I
described a scene in the book where
where Trump is sort of gobsmacked that
these guys have managed to figure out
that he's given money to Democrats that
he hasn't vote very often well of course
we all know these are these are these
are readily available public records
that you could probably pull up on your
phone if you if you cared to but Trump
was dazzled and I think he really
connected with Bannen on a personal
level they're both very kind of
swaggering alpha male dealmaker types
and from that moment on Bannon was a
part of Trump's political circle and
became a more important part as time
went on what's the devil's bargain
well the devil's bargain in the book is
I explained and the preface the book how
it was that I met Bannon
he had written article I read an article
I'd written about Sarah Palin and called
me up and said hey I have this
documentary film I've just done about
Palin will you come see it and I thought
okay and this was in 22 2011 we still
thought Palin might run for president in
2012 and I met him I didn't think a
whole lot of the film but Bannen himself
was a very interesting guy with a
distinct style and brand of populist
politics that didn't really have any
representation in Washington and he told
me Ben and did in 2011 that he thought
that Palin could be the candidate that
would carry this politics to the White
House so I argue in devil's bargain that
there the bargain implicit at the heart
of the ban and Trump relationship is
that vannin would give these ideas this
populist nationalism to a candidate and
get him to the White House but the flip
side of that bargain was that once there
the president Trump would faithfully
enact those policies and for the most
part that hasn't happened at least not
yet early on in the relationship you
have a chapter called where is my Steve
well that is a quote from Donald Trump
about Steve Bannon and one of the things
that I try and illuminate in the book is
how it is that these two men came
together I mean such unlikely background
such a strange marriage and yet such an
important relationship for understanding
how that this what I call the greatest
political upset in US presidential
history came about and in talking to
people around Trump at the time that he
met Steve ban and they said look Trump
is ordinarily surrounded by very
deferential staffers they were described
to me as lackeys I think we all know the
type the source said you know Steve was
the only alpha male in trumps universe
he liked
Bannen he respected the fact that Bannon
had gotten rich on business so he had a
certain co-equal standing with Trump and
Bannon as a former investment banker had
real experience managing ambitious
egotistical aggressive guys like Donald
Trump he wasn't wowed he wasn't knew and
so they really had a certain rapport and
so when Trump began to travel to
conservative political conferences in
2013 and 2014
trying to lay the groundwork for a
presidential bid he would look for
Bannon who would be at these conference
and say where's my Steve where's my
Steve and then he'd go find them and
here's an echo from another quote from
from the book from your writing the
surprise elevation of Bannon to head
Trump's campaign on August 17th hit
political Washington like a thunderclap
and to most insiders like a bad
punchline to Washington Republicans
Bannon was about the worst choice Trump
could have made because it's signaled
that rather than steer toward a
gentlemanly defeat that might preserve
Republican seats in the House and Senate
Trump was going to burn it all down and
route to a loss so ugly it might destroy
the party well at the time Bannon was
put in charge of the Trump campaign
which there was no warning there were no
trial balloons this just happened BAM I
think on a Wednesday morning the state
of the Trump campaign was was pure chaos
he had come off of a very dark
Republican National Convention doing OK
in the polls but then there were a
succession of Trump fights and scandals
he was fighting with Fox News and megyn
kelly he famously went after the parents
of the slain Muslim soldier kisser Khan
the father this was this was very
damaging to Trump standing in the polls
so come in August it looked as if Trump
were spiraling toward a blowout loss and
then lo and behold Steve Benin is put in
charge of the campaign and the reason
that Republicans were so negative toward
Bannon is that in his role as chairman
of Breitbart news he's been very
critical of Republicans he had helped
drive out House Speaker John Boehner the
year before and so unless you were part
of a very small subset of hard-right
Republican members of Congress house
freedom caucus if you had had any
experience at all with Steve Bannon in
Breitbart it was probably highly
negative and it was clear that bannon's
MO is to be more outrageous more out
stream and more extreme and more
aggressive than any mainstream political
consultant would be so there's a real
fear that van and in his eagerness to
kind of blow up the presidential race
would actually wind up blowing up the
Republican Party the president won and
the president in response to your book
it seems tweeting out
I love reading about all the geniuses
who were so instrumental in my election
success problem is most don't exist fake
news make America great again he's also
said he was his own strategist I think
I'm gonna use that as a book blurb on
the back of the paperback edition maybe
it may be just the top line but as
everyone knows Trump does not like
having a co-star and bannon's worst
experience I think so far in the
presidential administration came in
February after Time magazine famously
ran a cover of bannon's faced and
headlined the great manipulator it led
to this
belief and the culture we saw it
reflected on Saturday Night Live that
that quote-unquote president Bannon was
was really the guy in charge of things I
think that rub Trump's ego the wrong way
and Bannon was sort of cast out for a
while now he is he has worked his way
back into the inner circle but I think
the fact that my book puts him on the
cover and his one White House official
pointed out to me
Steve Banias name comes before Donald
Trump's name and the subtitle to your
book has rubbed Donald Trump the wrong
way but I encourage him to read the
whole book it has a happy ending from
Trump's point of view he wins at the
answer let's go to calls John in
Illinois a Democrat John good morning to
you hi good morning names John I have a
question for you're the author what is
Stevens take or a relationship with the
works of Julius Ebola EB Oh L a quite a
traditionalist so sorry so I actually
get into this in the book one of the
questions that I had for Bannon was how
did you come up with this idea of
nationalist right-wing politics and who
did you look to for inspiration there we
came out during the during the
presidential campaign but there was a
video of Bannon at a Vatican conference
in 2014 came out in which Bannon
mentioned the name Julius Evelyn for
those who aren't familiar Avila was
Benito Mussolini's fascist racial
theorist later went on to Nazi Germany
and one of the reasons that I think a
lot of people believe that Bannon is you
know white supremacist or a crypto
anti-semite are the fact that he's
familiar with people like Avila who are
very popular among white supremacists
today so he has been in that and he said
well I was looking for an intellectual
underpinning for my beliefs about
nationalism and the big nationalist
thinkers were most prominent in the 30s
and 40s and they included people like
Evelyn and so I do a section in the book
on the roots of bannon's nationalism it
mentions ev Allah but what Bannon told
me is that Evelyn was really a path back
to an earlier thinker a French
metaphysician and freemason named Rene
goony own who was kind of the Godfather
for Julius Evelyn and this group of
traditionalist thinkers who were
probably at the height of their
influence in the 1930s and 1940s and now
our back in the form of Bannon and
Alexander Dugan who is Vladimir Putin's
chief ideology so this is the strain
that connects Evelyn to Bannon to trump
Darrell in Los Angeles independent color
question or comment here I will comment
Joshua thank you for your book but
unfortunately the only people are going
to read it are the curious are the
people that have any kind of education
and listen I'm not here to fix the world
but if you look at how we're dumbing
down and how we're going back to these
archaic ideas you know from your last
guest in my opinion it was probably
Steve Bannon that made Trump go out
there and I'm sure trumps homophobic and
Steve Bannon lived in my had an office
of my friends building and you know he
was a strange guy told me all kinds of
stories this guy but that aside I didn't
vote for Bannon I didn't vote for Jeb I
didn't vote for these people that I
don't know were they educated I worked
all my life to be educated to understand
ideas and policies and all of that I
didn't graduate high school but for
God's sake
I'm smarter than most of these Harvard
or Stanford guys should you vote for the
president no no no IIIi voted the
primary for Bernie Sanders and then I
voted for Hillary reluctantly you know
not that she's not qualified but you
know I saw the errors but I did not want
a businessman like mr. Trump in the
office Joshua again other callers thank
you for your book and maybe you can
write it Dick and Jane version of it why
did you think it was important to write
a book about Steve banning why does it
matter well because the question
everyone has for the day after the
election I'm we and I say collectively I
think the Washington media Clinton's
campaign most of the people that I
circulate within Washington and my job
as a political reporter were just
shocked that this had happened and
nobody I don't think really believed
until about 10:00 p.m. on election night
the Trump could win and I remember
talking to people the next day I talked
to my mom kind of called up and said how
could this have happened you all told me
that Hillary Clinton what's gonna win
which I had and so I thought it was
important for someone to look back and
tell the full inside story of what had
really happened
and just because I had had up close
access to people like Bannon and Trump
going so far back I thought that I could
tell the story of that campaign and I
thought that the key to understanding
what happened in that election was
understanding the relationship between
Donald Trump and Steve Bannon because
together they were able to ride this
populist wave and win not only the GOP
nomination against what was thought to
be the strongest presidential field and
the Republican side in a generation but
beat Hillary Clinton who seemed as if
she had been ticketed for the White
House ever since she lost a brocco bomb
in 2008 and what about Donald Trump the
business man's relationship with the
establishment I want to show our viewers
a c-span interview with the new RNC
Chairman at the time Ryan's Priebus and
a question that he gets on our
newsmakers program back in 2011 from the
New York Times reporter Jeff
you said that all the Republican
candidates in the field right now are
credible is Donald Trump a credible
Republican presidential champion I don't
know if he's in the field or not but if
he decides to run you had a phone call
yeah I mean you know I think all these
guys are credible and and I and I think
that they've all have different angles
and different viewpoints that they're
gonna articulate and you know I think
it's gonna be up to the voters I don't
get to choose who the candidates going
to be but I have to make sure that we do
it we can do in our party to get them
across the finish is it good for the
party or good for the debate to have a
candidate or potential candidate like
him talking so much about is this
president and American citizen is the
further debate good for the part I mean
I think it's up to the primary voters to
decide that I mean obviously people
gonna have different opinions and you
know you have a lot of different groups
that are choosing two different
candidates that are running they're
gonna talk about different things at
different times I think it's up to the
primary voters I think having a
diversity of opinion is fine but
ultimately I think the voters usually
get it right and we'll have a candidate
and it's up to me to turn our party into
a functional operational committee that
can get that candidate cross yep just
green you write in the book that it was
moments like those that amused Donald
Trump why well it wasn't this is I
actually tell the story of this
interview in the book believe it or not
when Reince Priebus was first elected
chairman of the Republican National
Committee in 2011 the very first scandal
that he had to deal with as chairman was
that a donald trump scandal trump was
going out doing a media tour claiming
that barack obama had not been born in
the United States and I believe the
interview clip you just showed was
previous his first national interview is
RNC director and the reason I cited in
my book is because Priebus is confronted
about what is clearly a lie about Barack
Obama's birth and yet you see him
unwilling to kind of stand up and assert
himself and say there's no room for that
kind of talk in our party it's not true
I think that Priebus is weakness in in
the clip and and afterwards is one of
the
why the Republican Party was unable to
stop Donald Trump from as I call it in
book storming his way through the
Republican nomination and winning the
presidency Lisa and Louisville Kentucky
a Democrat hi Lisa how are you today
good good morning I think that uh Donald
Trump in a speed ban and identify with
each other more on the I hate to say
this prejudice level I don't think Steve
ban and believes that a black people
should be lead the United States but I
think he wants a separatist Society and
also I believe it's not from the face
about these are visas that Donald
Trump's always wanting he brings in
foreign workers to work his motels and
hotels and these high-tech jobs that
supposedly there's nobody in the US has
qualified for them that's just not true
I will II believe the main thing is they
want to drive the wages down and I don't
think Steven Willy believes in that okay
so let's get a response sorry I I think
that what Trump and Bannon share is an
understanding of the power of stoking
Americans resentments both economic
resentments racial resentments the story
I told the book of how they came
together I say on the one hand I traced
Trump's political lineage and if you go
back to 1988 when he first started
speaking about running for president he
actually does strike a lot of the same
notes that he struck in 2016 the idea
that the u.s. is being taken advantage
of by foreign countries
back then it was Japan now it's China
the element that Steve Bannon added to
that mix that was so powerful and so
combustible in the 2016 cycle was the
issue of immigration taking a hard line
on immigration both in terms of vowing
to deport immigrants who are here
illegally and even shutting the borders
and in reducing legal immigration Trump
didn't say those kinds of things five
ten years ago but once he met ban and he
began to and it really resonated out
there on the campaign trail I think more
than anything else that was the issue
that carried Trump to the Republican
nation and I think that is what he and
Steve ban and have in common I don't
know whether Trump really believes it I
maybe does I know for certain that
Bannon believes it let's go to Tampa
Florida Linda independent caller you're
on the air with Josh green hi Josh
Thank You c-span for taking my call my
question is the propaganda that's
floating around
I just find it like ridiculous I
remember reading about the propaganda
that occurred in Germany at the time and
an entire generation of people were
raised to believe to fight to kill to do
horrible things they did and their
montage back then was make Germany great
again to me I find it a little
ridiculous to hear the president Bannon
and all these people saying make America
great again it just brings that back
into my mind I find it very very
displeasing okay Linda that's green well
I think Trump understands intuitively
maybe better than any politician in my
lifetime since Ronald Reagan the
visceral power of phrases like that to
activate voters I mean I think it
connects on an emotional level make
America great again in a way that
Democratic slogans simply do not if you
read the New Democrats loving a better
deal better it sounds like it was swat
teams by you know a group of high-priced
McKinsey consultants it doesn't have
that kind of authenticity and I think
the Trump understands that make America
great again does as far as propaganda
it's interesting the caller could
mention that because Steve Bennett
actually studies and admires a lot of
the propaganda film makers from the
1920s in the 1930s he is name-checked
and being compared to Leni Riefenstahl
the Nazi film maker and well I don't
think that vannin shares
Riefenstahl views he does admire her
ability to shape the public message and
shape public sentiment through film and
that's absolutely a lesson that he's
tried to bring to the Trump campaign
with some success did Steve Bannon
sanction this book how did you talk to
him for the book
if so how for how long well you didn't
sanction the book but as I said earlier
I met Bannon in 2011 and began hanging
around with him because as a political
reporter I'm always looking for
interesting characters who break the
mold and and and Bandhan if nothing else
breaks the mold of the type of person
you encounter in Washington so I would
interview him over the years I had I had
you know tens or hundreds of hours of
interview tapes with him I didn't
actually write about him though until
2015 I did a cover story in Bloomberg
Businessweek magazine built on this
elaborate plan that Bannon had conceived
to tear down Hillary Clinton who
everybody knew was gonna be the likely
Democratic nominee and so in the course
of reporting that piece I think I spent
eight months on it and traveled to
Florida with van and and interviewed
everybody around him so he didn't he
didn't sanction the book I decided to
write it on my own I don't think he's
real happy that it's out there we've
seen what happens to Steve Ben and when
his profile gets too high but he did
continue to talk to me after that
Businessweek profile because I think he
appreciated the fact that a mainstream
media reporter was willing to take
seriously what it was he was doing and
explain it to people and then once he
got into the Trump campaign actually
remember calling him that morning and
saying hey buddy you know everybody's
gonna come after you now every reporter
because you are now in charge of a
presidential campaign
don't forget who is there talking to you
and taking you seriously before you were
running Donald Trump's campaign in two
bannon's credit you know we kept talking
throughout the campaign and and so all
of this is included in in the book who
else did you talk to you for the book I
dozens if not hundreds of people I
haven't listed in the preface but you
know my job is a political reporter the
last three years was really to cover the
rise of the populist right and I was
more or less embedded with the Trump
campaign I didn't do a lot of reporting
on the Hillary Clinton campaign this
cycle so just in the course of doing my
job as a political reporter for
Bloomberg I did long profiles of Donald
Trump of Reince Priebus of a lot of the
people who wound up being instrumental
in the campaign so the book really draws
on all of that reporting of course I did
additional reporting after Trump was
elected spent some time up in Trump
Tower and hang
around with administration officials did
you talk to the president I talked to
the president there's a chapter in the
book where I talked to the president
about how he intends to put his stamp on
the Republican Party I sort of had this
idea that when Trump acquires a property
whether it's a building or a golf course
what does he do he puts the Trump brand
on it and so I asked Trump in the book I
said what you know now that you've won
the Republican nomination clearly you
have a different set of ideas than all
the Republicans you just feed how are
you gonna put the Trump stamp the Trump
brand on the Republican Party and he
goes for a bit in the book about how he
wants it to become a Workers Party and
so that is that is an idea that I think
was very powerful the Trump recognized
that the Republican message as it was
being conveyed by the GOP establishment
over the last 10 20 years really wasn't
rad resonating in the Trump by making a
pitch to kind of blue-collar
working-class
people in promising different things
would be more of a more effective
messenger to base Republican voters and
I think in the event that wound up being
true and it's something that he pivots
back to today you know he's sitting down
at the the cabinet meeting leading a
cabinet meeting yesterday with his new
White House chief of staff any minute
immediately turns to the economy and
touts the numbers this morning on
Twitter saying stock market could hit
all-time high again 22,000 today it was
18,000 only six months ago on election
day
mainstream media seldom mentions this
well I work for Bloomberg we're a
financial journalism we mentioned all
day long every day so if you want good
news about the stock market he's what
he's welcome to read Bloomberg ah I I
don't agree quite I think during the
campaign he had a very blue-collar
oriented economic message we're gonna
make America great again we're gonna
bring back manufacturing jobs we're
going to hold off and subordinate Wall
Street banks like Goldman Sachs who are
ripping off the little little guy very
populist message that you could have you
heard echoes of what Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren would say that was back
from the campaign as president he hasn't
govern in the way that he implied he
would he is stock fresh Ilan's
administration with people like Gary
Cohn Stephen minuchin Dena Powell all of
whom are very high-ranking Goldman Sachs
executives his health care plan which it
looked like has now failed was going to
take a lot of money from health care
spending redirected toward tax cuts
mostly for very wealthy donors so the
irony of trumps plight as president is
that he won the Republican primary by
running against in defeating by showing
the weakness of the standard Republican
policy ideas but then once he got into
the White House he turned around and
basically agreed to try and enact them
had Trump I say in the afterword of the
book I take a stab at explaining why
things have gone so wrong so fast and I
posit that if Trump had done something
more true to the vision he put out on
the campaign trail let's say for
instance he'd begun with a trillion
dollar infrastructure plan not only
would that have been truer to who Trump
is he's a builder he could put his Trump
stamp on all the bridges and roads he
built but he would have split the
Democratic Party because the party's
labor union base was already fairly
supportive of Trump and had he come out
and launched a big infrastructure plan
it would have created a lot of jobs I
think we would he would be in a very
different situation than he wound up in
where instead he wants to pass a health
care law that would have cost anywhere
from 15 to 23 million people health care
and he made a real mistake and and
taking the direction that he has but now
that he has a new chief of staff now
that he's tried to hit reset maybe he
can move things back in a more positive
direction let's go to Joan in Rochester
Minnesota Democrat you're on the air
Joan hi thanks a lot and thank you for
c-span I had heard on TV one of the
programs that back in 2013
Bannen had proclaimed that he would run
the United States into the ground and
work at destroying this country and I
think we're on a very bad path along
those lines when we put up a
all in Mexico and leave people out of
the country we are in an isolationist
position where the American people are
completely isolated from the rest of the
world and that's kind of their goal
there Joan let me go back to what you
said you where did you hear those
comments by Bannen I heard I wasn't a
comment by Bannen it was a comment made
about vana on TV I do not remember what
okay it was but I got stuck in my mind
and I think of Trump and Bannon as Trump
being like Joel gray and cabaret as a
front for what's going on behind the
scenes which was the fascism rise of
fascism okay well let's talk about Steve
bannon's influence well I think that
what Bannon has been quoted saying is
not that he wants to blow up the country
but that he wants to blow up the
political establishments of both parties
he's been described
he has been reporter of Daily Beast that
said vannin had described himself as a
Leninist in 2013 and he wanted to blow
up the system that may be what the
caller is referring to and I think
that's an accurate representation of
what Bannon thought he was doing in 2013
and to give him credit he is pretty much
achieved that he certainly blew up the
Republican establishment by helping
Trump win the Republican nomination
there was not a single Republican in
Washington who wanted that to happen and
the party resisted and resisted until
the very last moment and I think by the
fact by virtue of the fact that Trump
defeated Hillary Clinton he has also to
an extent blown up the Democratic
establishment everybody in washing every
Democrat expected that Clinton would be
President
now that she has lost it's not clear
what direction the party is going to
take and there is a bit of a I wouldn't
quite call it a civil war but a tug of
war within the Democratic Party between
the populist Bernie Sanders wing and the
more mainstream establishment forces who
are loyal if not to Hillary Clinton
specifically to the idea of clintonism
in a more modern mainstream Democratic
Party and that's a that's a debate
think we're gonna see play out over the
next three or four years as Democrats
try and produce a nominee who can unify
the party in defeat Donald Trump
Katherine Mobile Alabama Democrat yes I
have a lot of questions for your guest I
haven't read your book yet but I fully
intend to the first I'd like to make a
little comment first and see what you
think about it the thing that worries me
is I was born in Mississippi and raised
from the 50s and the 60s in Alabama
Mississippi so I know what I have been
seeing and for eight years I watched it
in horror and the first thing is why is
the changing of the meaning of words
become so easily done by the news media
like y'all are calling you say fake news
look people it's just lives let's call
it what it is when people lie they need
to be called out that they're telling
lies the next thing is you say that they
were sick of being politically incorrect
well that just means they wanted to be
rude and crude in the population when is
enough enough hate anger and rage got
elected I own a pack of feral dogs which
I personally had to capture in the woods
and my dogs had to be either put down
they said because they couldn't be
adopted out it was a family of dogs that
had moved on to my car my country
property now and I've owned dogs all my
life I didn't want to have to deal with
this in my 60s but I figured the good
Lord just gave it to me
these dogs are fun when they are
together okay but when they are apart I
mean when they are apart they are calm
when they are together they woke up into
a fever that is what is happening in our
population okay let me let me let me
stop you there so I can tackle some of
these questions before I miss them all
on the fake news I don't think that
that's the media saying fake news I
think that is the charge that's being
lobbed at us by Donald Trump and by
Trump partisans the original meaning of
the term fake news back in the campaign
meant literally fake news news that was
fabricated on these websites in
Macedonia and sent across Facebook in
order to try
or disillusion people into believing
something had happened that hadn't
happened it was literally propaganda
what's happened is that Donald Trump has
appropriated the term and begun to apply
it to real stories in the real news
media that he doesn't like and that's
something that's been taken out by other
Republicans by a lot of Trump supporters
so it's changed the meaning of the term
as far as the willingness to call lies
lies I disagree on that one too if you
look at some of the reporting in the New
York Times and The Washington Post they
have been doing wonderful work and if
gone further than I've ever seen a
mainstream journalism outlet go in not
using using euphemisms and stating
outright that Donald Trump lied about
something you even see it on cable news
Chiron's they've begun fact-checking
lies by the president in real time so I
give the media a lot of credit for
having worked hard to let readers and
viewers know when something isn't true I
think that's a positive development in
the news media you've seen Chiron's rate
recently where they say the President
Trump says and in parentheses so-and-so
disputes the claim well not even
disputes the claim the claim isn't true
I mean you can see this on on CNN you
can see it on MSNBC one of the
criticisms of cable news in particular
up to and after the Trump administration
was that Trump would tweet something
that wasn't true or make an attack that
wasn't true and cable news producers
would simply broadcast that tweet
leading readers or viewers to believe
especially if you had the sound turned
off or you're in a cab or just catching
another corny ride that what was being
asserted was in fact true when it wasn't
true so I think the media collectively
has has made a much greater effort to
identify and call out misinformation
when it happens let's go to Salisbury
North Carolina Andy's watching there a
Republican good morning good morning my
question for Josh is this all came from
the learned about this through the
Guardian and breaks it and how Cambridge
analytics and
Mercer two folks said that on the
Breitbart I believe and I believe Mercer
was the largest private donor for Trump
and they describe what happened and
breaks it as a I guess part of
Cambridge's and analytic business is
psyops propaganda whatever that's
unleashed on the civilian population
that really worries me and still worries
me but I guess my big question is how
deeply involved is the capers analytic
and what they call big data it is that's
great that's a great question so I
actually have a chapter in devil's
bargain about Robert Mercer the
billionaire co-ceo Renaissance
Technologies big hedge fund who was one
of the major donors to not only Donald
Trump and especially the Steve ban he's
essentially Steve bannon's benefactor
and setting up a lot of these different
groups and one of the the businesses
that Mercer invests and I believe is the
u.s. arm of Cambridge analytical which
is a data science firm that has become
very aggressively involved not just in
the brains of campaign but in US
politics and was I had data scientists
who were embedded in the Trump campaign
actually did a story for Business Week
in October about a month before the
election where I traveled down with my
colleague Sasha Eisenberg who is sort of
the foremost political data expert in
journalism and we were given access to
this group their kind of inner sanctum
of Cambridge and Trump and what they
were doing on the data science front and
they had PhDs and astrophysicists and
all these Cambridge Data folks they
weren't doing psyops is the caller
described I think that tends to get a
little exaggerated but what they were
doing was very sophisticated polling and
data modeling and what that got them and
I explained this toward the very end of
the book is that it gave them a better
insight into who actually was going to
come out and vote and who Trump's voters
really were one of the things that was
so confusing and flustering to the
mainstream media to mainstream political
analysts into pollsters was that Trump
voters Trump Republicans had different
traits and tenets than traditional
mainstream Republican voters had so
Cambridge analytical on behalf of the
Trump campaign spent a lot of time and a
lot of money modeling the distinct
universe of Trump voters how they
differed from Republicans it was very
interesting they cared about different
issues some of them cared more about gun
control they cared less about tax reform
they tended to be more rural older and
whiter than traditional Republican
voters and because the Cambridge folks
understood this they were better at
targeting these voters and getting them
to come out to the polls than anyone
really realized that they would be and
so that is why on Election Day you
suddenly had this mass influx to the
polls of vast numbers of rural people
elderly whiter folks people who hadn't
traditionally voted in elections were
showing up to vote for Donald Trump and
that was something that most people just
didn't anticipate but the fact that they
came out decided the election for Donald
Trump and what about this data and how
the the candidate Donald Trump reflected
that in his speeches ticked off the
issues that each of these groups cared
about was the second amendment moving
that to NAFTA etc exactly so so by and
large these voters were less concerned
about traditional Republican issues a
hawkish foreign policy an emphasis on
the positive aspects of free trade and a
focus on cutting high-end marginal tax
rates for the wealthy none of those
things did you hear from Donald Trump on
the campaign what you heard instead was
we are gonna be smarter about the war we
fight which is based like we're gonna
focus on the middle class and the
mainstream bring back manufacturing jobs
making America great again which is
something they liked and Trump also I
think embodied and spoke about cultural
issues in a way that
resonated with Republican voters in a
way that more Washington centric elite
Republicans people like Marco Rubio or
Jeb Bush or Paul Ryan just couldn't do
that he couldn't connect with these
voters on a visceral level and I think
the fact that so many of these people
really did show up in the polls defying
expectations of people like me shows how
effective Trump was at understanding who
his voters were how to reach them and
how to activate them Norfolk Virginia
Marvin independent caller you're on the
air with Josh green Donald Trump
President of the United States for what
he announced about his casinos and how
he did not want black people working in
his casinos this he has divided this
country so bad I think the Congress
needs to hold him down like they did on
the vote for him to sign that paper with
Russia something has to be done because
the country is too different or divided
on the dis man he is not a good person
and the Congress need to sit down and
we'll leave it there Marvin Josh green
this morning in Politico Senator Jeff
Flake as part of him an excerpt from his
new book conscience of a conservative
writes that it's time for Republicans
like himself to stand up to the
executive branch to this president yeah
I mean did this this is a kind of energy
that has been building up beneath the
radar among a lot of elected Republicans
who did not support Trump but understood
that they were saddled with him that he
was their president and that it would
try and make a go of it as the Trump
administration has descended into chaos
as its legislative agenda has gone off
the rails and now failed with a health
care vote I a lot of these Republicans
tell reporters like
you know off-the-record or not not for
publication that you know we're really
losing our patience here there's gonna
come a time it's not there yeah there's
gonna come a time when we were going to
break publicly with the president and I
think Blake's book is the first
high-profile example of that happening
and there are two things that I'm gonna
be watching for in the days and weeks
ahead one is this Jeff Flake back up
these complaints and attacks with actual
action does he studies heat does he
announce I'm not gonna support any of
trumps items until he changes his
behavior or does this or that and then
of course the other question is will
other people follow is this an issue
where the dam is breaking and the party
in mass is going to move against Trump
or is an example of another what we're
known as never Trump errs during the
campaign somebody coming out saying you
know this is unacceptable who winds up
basically being a lone voice in the
wilderness while the rest of the party
keeps marching behind Trump I think
that's that's the big open question
around Flake page in South Carolina
James Republican hi
first of all thank you for taking my
call and you've got a great program I
love it they look forward to reading the
book I'm going to touched on a couple of
points here one was I just heard one
someone was blaming Trump for the
division of the United States and that's
a you know everybody's got their opinion
but the fact is we've been a divided
nation since the 1860s during a civil
war after the Civil War we've never
stopped being a divided nation from what
I can see by the numbers and the facts
Trump has done a lot given that the
Democratic Party has done nothing to
contribute to getting anything done
which I think that both parties really
need to get in there and work together
and because when it's all said and done
we're all Americans we're you know
forget being a Democrat an independent
or whatever party you want to be you're
still an American acting as well I
recall is right I mean the process of
political polarization in America which
was so evident in
campaign has been moving steadily toward
the extremes since about the mid-1970s
so you can go look at charts of
congressional leaders and how many
people were in the center of versus at
the extreme and there is literally a
parting there so certainly Donald Trump
is not solely responsible for the
divisions and our politics that being
said the story I tell in devil's bargain
is that Steve Bannon in particular
realized that these divisions were there
and thought that rather than bringing
people together he could Stoke them
deepen them and thereby drive out into
the political process people who had
actually become disillusioned who didn't
really think there was anybody in
politics who represented their interest
that was a very interesting strategy
because it was different than what a lot
of Republican consultants were pushing
for at the time and it wound up working
as far as the lack of democratic
cooperation with the Trump agenda I
think one of the reasons for that is the
Trump rather than pursuing a buy pot of
a potentially bipartisan policy like a
big infrastructure plan that would build
roads and bridges and give jobs to
Democratic Union voters for instance he
went instead in trying to take apart
Barack Obama's signature achievement the
affordable care act and Democrats just
aren't gonna get in board with that
they're not gonna be bipartisan just for
the sake of being bipartisan they have
real policy interests at stake that they
see as being under assault by the likes
of Donald Trump and Steve ban and so I
think one of the potentially positive
developments of the Republican health
care plan failing is that there are a
lot of Republicans and Democrats talking
behind the scenes about potential
bipartisan solutions on health care
reform and in fact Mitch McConnell even
came out about three weeks ago and said
and he meant this as a threat at the
time
but he said if Republicans can't vote
through Obamacare repeal we are gonna
have no choice but to work with
Democrats well I think the caller sounds
like he thinks like that might be a good
thing and who knows we may be headed in
that direction
let's talk to Chris is it
[ __ ] Jacksonville North Carolina yes
thanks for taking my call I just want to
say this a mr. grimwig Magritte mr.
Gregersen is a bunch of gobbledygook
the truth of the matter is if you
understand politics 101 and that is if
everything is done by political parties
everything is done by political parties
and the Republican Party has just lost
control of the Republican Party because
the political party is fractured in so
many different areas
unlike the Democrat Party is
consolidated a Republican Party has so
many different so many different
opinions in it they lost control of the
Republican Party gonna fall and Steve
Barron is not a political savvy they're
not smart they're not these great minds
that he wants try to portray a mask and
they beat they beat everybody in your
Republican Party I mean clearly clearly
the Republican Party is in chaos because
they lost to a guy with absolutely no
political experience who was considered
a joke in a punch line by everybody in
politics and in the popular culture and
together Trump and banna and this is a
story that I tell in the book turned out
to be better analysts of both Democratic
and Republican politics than anybody in
Washington they absolutely destroyed the
Republican Party's preferred candidate
and route to winning the White House so
I don't think anybody can argue with any
real sense that they were not effective
or influential maybe not in the White
House and in a legislative sense but
certainly they were in the election this
this was I believe the greatest upset in
US political history and so you need to
understand and give credit to the people
that pulled it off and at the White
House now with traditional Republicans
as part of the inner circle
Reince Priebus has left but there are
other traditional Republicans there and
Steve Bannon still there Kellyanne
Conway other folks who is influencing
the present the most or does it change
on a daily basis and are they fighting
with each other the different factions
within the way well the one thing we've
learned about the Trump White House is
they're always fighting with each other
the different factions are always
fighting maybe now the general Kelly has
come in as chief of staff you can impose
some order
and calm down those those internecine
battles but I think that the traditional
Republican Party is less represented
than ever in Trump's inner circle and it
wasn't very well represented to begin
with
you did have Reince Priebus the chairman
of the party although he's a very weak
chief of staff
you had Sean Spicer from the RNC
although he was really a spokesman he
wasn't a policy guy and neither of them
had any legislative experience I think
they were slightly miss cast in the role
as being liaisons to Paul Ryan Mitch
McConnell in the Republican Congress my
vice president Mike Pence vice president
Mike Pence is probably the strongest tie
to traditional Republicans in the House
and Senate although even pence hasn't
served in Congress in quite a while he
came as governor of Indiana so while he
is liked and respected by everybody in
Congress and while he does have an
experienced legislative staff in order
to succeed you have to kind of manage
around both the distractions that Trump
himself seems to throw up on a pretty
regular basis and also all the fighting
and jockeying for position and Trump
staff and ask the question of who he
listens to I think that changes from day
to day you know ten days ago I guess 12
days ago now Jared Kushner the Trump's
the president Trump son-in-law Ivanka
Trump his daughter wanted to bring in
Anthony's Gurmukhi as White House
communications director
Reince Priebus and Steve ban and
bitterly objected they were overruled
and now flash-forward two weeks and the
president apparently is not listening to
those two anymore Bannon gets his way
scaramouche E is gone there's a new
White House chief of staff so I think it
changes from day to day and for all I
know from hour to hour whoo-hoo Trump is
listening to and why he's doing what he
does the book devil's bargain
Steve Bannon Donald Trump in the
storming of the presidency Joshua green
the author thank you for your time this
morning in the conversation thanks so
much for having me